Rose is a Las Vegas staple and now you
can not only taste the best but learn
from the best too joining us to tell us
more about their taste and learn program
is Ferraro's executive chef mimo Ferraro
welcome Mercedes thank you for having me
very excited I love this taste and learn
I'm All About The Taste part I've tasted
many things at Ferraro's but the learn
actually is very intriguing tell us a
little bit about the program so we are
13 years in to taste and learn and it's
an Interactive Learning Experience where
we have a wine producer or
representative from the distributor come
over and we'll put a presentation on
about the the wines that we're featuring
and 99 of the time we feature Italian
wines for this and then I study the
wines and I pair each wine specific each
dish specifically to the wine you know
so this month in October we are doing a
taste of learning with Luigi baduano
wines and VD GD via wines menu
especially calculus you know starting
off with a little bit of a halibut
that'll go with our Bianco wine the
dragon from Luigi and then we're going
to get into a wild mushroom and porcini
ravioli with a truffle butter sauce then
we're going to get into a formatto which
is like a cheese flan that we're going
to do with a crispy prosciutto and then
we're going to finish that off with a
braised rabbit I do have a version of a
rabbit here on display but look at that
I'm going to do this one a little bit
different with a little bit of you know
more red wine and some prune in the dish
as well I think it'll be a great and
just accompany the barola with that dish
so let's talk a little little bit about
something that you have started here
that looks uh just so fresh and
delicious tell us a little bit about
that absolutely this is our buffalo
mozzarella that we import from Italy
from Puglia three times a week on the
bottom is a pistachio pesto that we make
in-house a little bit of watercress some
rainbow micro greens a little bit of
fresh peas and then we top that off with
some crushed pistachios as well you know
that we have toasted I have good drizzle
of an extra virgin olive oil
have a little bit of a the salad dressed
with a white balsamic honey Citrus
dressing and then a little basil oil to
kind of finish things off and this is on
our menu now you know to accompany our
homemade fresh pastas and our extensive
wine list with little over 1800 wines
right now so you know we take a lot of
pride in our wine program and the
freshness and quality of our food how
long has has Las Vegas been lucky enough
to have ferraros we're going on 37 years
37 years if you've never been you've got
to go just the freshest most wonderful
food and I love how you guys will come
out and you'll talk to the patrons see
how everything is going
um what just be growing up and and being
here for 37 years what have you what
have you learned about this city
you really have to take care of the
locals and just be a part of the
community and you know people like to be
recognized you know so with you know
family owned and operated business for
all these years we've made those
relationships and everybody who comes
into our restaurant from guests to our
staff is all part of extended family
everybody feels like you're a VIP when
you go to Ferraris and that's what I
love about it and again this taste and
learn program going on for 13 years and
you can be a part of it if they want to
sign up do they just call the restaurant
they can call the restaurant it does
sell out very fast so we encourage you
to kind of just get ahead of it we again
we do them every month and it's usually
the third Saturday of the month and it's
from five o'clock it is ninety dollars
per person all inclusive that includes
gratuity and taxes
um you know start off with a little bit
of Prosecco as you're mingling and
getting the feel for things and we get
into food and wine I love it all right
thank you so much Jillian I'll send it